all right what's up guys Peter Brown
with GameSpot here I'm walking on the
infinite deck and I'm here with Matthew
Carell this is a is a deck meant for VRS
currently in development let's you walk
in X Y Z and all sorts of directions
Matthew can you give us a bit about the
infinite egg while I try to maintain my
composure sure infinite deck is the
world's first active which means
actually mechanical omnidirectional
treadmill it's been in development for
about five years by our president George
Berger and this is a control system that
lets you not only stay in the center of
this without falling off and be safely
supported it also puts those inputs into
virtual reality so you can walk through
endless worlds in VR alright so what is
the trick that makes this thing work
because obviously I feel like there's a
sensor on my back that is detecting my
orientation maybe not I don't know can
you give me an idea of how this works
nailed it yes so there is a sensor array
that is taking every forward step that
you make and it's negating it it's
taking you back to zero so if you go
ahead and just stop just stop take your
zero and stop and then if you want to
try and run off of it it's gonna
actually keep you from doing that so it
keeps you safe alright so this is
probably a little bit far off from
coming to market I assume are you guys
eyeing you know eventually people have
this in their living room or is this
more of an amusement thing that was
gonna be like an amusement park yeah
this isn't something that we're
expecting to sell to consumers just yet
it's something that we want to get to
the high-end market we're looking for
strategic partners right now hahaha and
we want them to help us fix this and
make this perfect for consumers one day
so that's our goal is to get consumers
in the near future but for right now
just strategic partners and then
high-end markets all right Thank You
Matthew this is the infinite net compete
around for GameSpot stay tuned for more
coverage from CES
you